[Music]
we talked about this a bunch of times or
over the years not so much on the air
but whenever we bump into each other at
cool parties I always go to cool parties
you know that about me he gets me in
yeah you gotta let him in sneak run back
again
I come from Brookline Massachusetts you
come from the town right next door
actually the town that was our sort of
rival town Newton Newton Massachusetts
yeah and it was funny cuz that's the
team that we we played you guys in
football I was on the track team so I
ran track against you guys that was the
big thing we got to get Newton we got to
get new you grew up there and I'm
curious because one of the things I
notice about Newton is if they had their
own slang there was like a town it's a
very nice town but there's like a newton
slang that no other town has you guys
just what did you invent it as a
practical joke yeah well I come from
Newton is like a there's a lot of
villages in Newton and I come from this
part called Nome anthem and there's this
so I can take a predominantly Italian
neighborhood and there's this like weird
slang but like for example they would
say something like yeah we were down the
Conaty of there's some question Jim was
down there mush together some question
with down the corner yeah I get that's
all Massachusetts yeah and there was
some question Gerald's down there I
don't know what you're talking about so
question quiz your Gibble's know I could
like my friends my friend at home his
head is probably exploding right yeah
but that means some really pretty girls
down there buddy no it doesn't
back there does there's some quick Joe
jiggles down there mush mush mush what's
mush is like like hey hey dude hey mush
like a yoke yeah it's like a yo yeah say
yo mush okay so you actually need a
translation guide to walk into that part
of Newton Massachusetts it's because
there's nothing like that anywhere else
and I used to hear you guys say things
and I'd be like I don't know what
they're talking about I still don't
really don't know if they know what
they're talking about
you left Newton you very young age you
left to go to act to be an actor you're
good yeah how old were you at the time
there's almost 18 18 yeah well your
parents when you go to your parents and
you say I want to go and and it was
because so many people say they're gonna
go and and and be an actor in the big
city and it doesn't work out where your
parents supportive when you told them uh
no no ma'am I told my mother I'm going
to you know I was I was a carpenter I
was working in a frame and crew and um I
told my mother I think I'm gonna quit
this and I'm gonna move to New York and
be an actor and she said why Matthew
what do you know about acting I said
nothing I'm gonna go try and figure it
out
uh-huh so what does she say now thanks
for the Mercedes
pretty sweet